[Musique]
nous sommes à québec la plus
septentrionale des villes de russie ont
la tâche principale consiste à survivre
au froid aux conditions extrêmes et un
environnement hostile
lorsque l'union soviétique s'est
effondré cet endroit est devenue une
ville fantôme
aujourd'hui c'est un des ports maritimes
dynamique le long de la route maritime
du nord ambitieux projet du pays dans
l'arctique visant à remodeler le
commerce international évêque est
également le site d'une expérience
audacieuse qui en a fait la première
ville au monde à être alimentée par des
réacteur nucléaire flottant
voyons à quoi ressemble la vie dans
cette ville atomique russe en plein
essor
nous sommes tous comme une grande
famille quelle que soit leur nationalité
tout le monde s'entend bien ici
de temps en temps la ville est saisi par
un vent violent
aurait péché ou laissez moi vous montrer
quelque chose
et qu'avez vous mangez au dîner hier je
ne mange pas je fais un régime
oui ciboule 16 dollars pièce
certaines parties de perez ressemble
toujours à une ville fantôme même de nos
jours la neige devient parfois noir
bebek est situé à tchoukotka la région
la plus orientale du pays limitrophes de
l'alaska ce n'est pas une île mais les
habitants considèrent toujours le reste
de la russie comme le continent
peut-être parce qu'ils se sentent isolés
il n'existe par exemple pas de route
permanente ou de liaisons ferroviaires
avec québec il n'ya que deux options le
brise glace où les avions nous ne sommes
pas encore arrivés à québec mais nous
sommes déjà fatigués par le voyage
cela fait plus de 24 heures que nous
sommes partis de moscou
nous nous sommes d'abord envolé pour
novossibirsk on est allé plus loin vers
l'est jusqu'à la ville de maga dan
on a dû passer la nuit
on est sur le dernier tronçon
un vol de deux heures de maga d'annappes
évêques dans un avion de l'ère
soviétique
[Musique]
la n 28 qui nous a emmenés vers paix
avec ave les plus petites cabines de
toilettes que j'ai jamais vu mais je ne
me plains pas là où nous allons on ne
peut pas s'attendre à du confort
[Musique]
l'une des premières choses qui frappe
avec et qu'il n'y a pas d'arbres
rien le sol est ici tellement gelée que
rien ne pousse et cela rend le paysage
austère et morne
donc pour y mettre un peu de vie à
peindre des bâtiments en orange ou en
rose mais peut-être pas la pire des
idées
évêque est connu pour ses conditions
météorologiques difficiles mais il ne
s'agit pas seulement du froid
de temps en temps la ville est
terrorisée par un vent violent appelé
you jacques l'oeil ou jacques est si
puissant qu'il y a des vidéos de
personnes qu'ils renversent ou qui
l'obligent à se déplacer en rampant
car elles ne peuvent pas se relever
[Musique]
entre s il vous plait
zoya sauf qu'à une résidente nous montre
sa tenue d'hiver un manteau de fourrure
de vison
elle sait que les défenseurs des animaux
n'aimeront pas ça et elle s'en moque ap
évêques si vous n'avez pas de vêtements
suffisamment chaud vous pouvez mourir à
quelques mois fait-il froid ap évêques
en hiver il fait parfois 45 robben 48
extrêmement froid vous sortez dehors
quand même bien sûr
je le climat rigoureux influence tous
les aspects de la vie de pévèle
laissez-moi vous montrer quelque chose
à cause du permafrost les communications
de la ville se trouvent principalement
en surface et sont cachés dans des
coffrages en béton comme celui ci c'est
également devenu une alternative
populaire aux trottoirs habituels qui
sont parfois impraticables surtout en
hiver
donc comme on dit quand vous êtes à rome
ou dans notre cas à bec nous allons
grimper sur l'une de ses lignes de
communication et nous déplacer en ville
comme des locaux
la plupart des bâtiments résidentiels de
pévèle ont été construits sur pilotis
l'espace existant entre le bas de la
maison et le sol gelé en permanence aide
à conserver la chaleur à l'intérieur
mais il y en a qui sont allés encore
plus loin semble-t-il dans la lutte
contre le froid il ya un bâtiment ap
évêques avec des bouteilles de verre
vide incrusté dans les murs en béton
vous pouvez même les voir de l'extérieur
cette couche d'air supplémentaire est
supposé conserver la chaleur je n'ai
jamais entendu parler de cette
technologie mais je ne sais pas si c'est
efficace il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir
pourquoi ce bâtiment a été abandonnée je
suppose que si vous voulez survivre en
tchoukotka vous devez rester créatif
il reste encore de nombreuses structures
et monuments de l'ère soviétique dans la
ville la plupart de existe depuis la
fondation de québec en 1930
l'or et d'autres métaux précieux ont
attiré les gens et transformer l'endroit
en une ville arctique en plein essor
initialement au moins trois camps de
goulag se trouvait tapé avec la main
d'oeuvre bon marché et est utile pour
cette colonie en croissance rapide
[Musique]
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique a
eu un effet dévastateur sur pv en
l'absence de soutien du continent la
ville a rapidement perdu la moitié de sa
population et de nombreux bâtiments
résidentiels se sont trouvés
complètement abandonné certaines parties
de pévèle ressemble toujours à une ville
fantôme
[Musique]
les gens voulaient si désespérément
partir dans les années 90 qu'ils aient
changé parfois des appartements entier
contre des billets d'avion pour moscou
des années d'exposition à des conditions
météorologiques extrêmes ont fait qu'il
est maintenant impossible que les gens
puissent à nouveau vivre dans ces
maisons et il est trop cher de les
démolir
regardez ce que la nature a fait à ses
bâtiments dès que les gens laissent
quelque chose ici la nature s'en empare
on dirait que c'est comme une sorte de
message tu ne baissez pas la garde où
vous pourriez être le prochain
comment trouvez-vous la ville elle
dépérit où elle prend vie non pourquoi
tout se développe le 5e district a été
entièrement reconstruit vous pouvez voir
de nouvelles maisons une centrale
électrothermique est apparue une
nouvelle église a été consacré évêque se
développe oui tout à fait
un projet a en particulier insuffler une
nouvelle vie à la ville et l'a aidé à
sortir de la dévastation des années 90
est récemment devenu le site d'une
expérience audacieuse qui en fait la
première ville au monde alimenté par une
centrale nucléaire flottante
cet énorme chose que vous voyez là bas
est essentiellement une plate-forme
maritime à deux réacteurs atomiques
comparables à ceux des sous marins
personne n'a jamais fait ça auparavant
la centrale du nom de l'académicien
lomonosov a été assemblé à saint
pétersbourg puis transporté ap vec par
voie maritime cela s'est avéré beaucoup
moins cher et plus facile que
d'acheminer des milliers de travailleurs
et des tonnes de matériaux pour sa
construction dans une région reculée
comme la tchoukotka la russie prévoit de
construire une petite flotte de ses
stations et de l'utiliser pour alimenter
des installations éloignés et peut-être
même pour des plateformes pétrolières et
gazières offshore
services et monde se pose la question de
la sécurité s'il ya une tempête en mer
ou un tsunami qu'arrivera-t-il alors aux
réacteurs nucléaires
on a mené des tests de résistance qui
ont montré que même si un tsunami
arracher nos bouts d'un barrage et que
la plateforme s'échouer sur le rivage la
sécurité serait en tout cas assuré il
n'y aurait pas d'émission de substances
radioactives
dans les eaux autour de la centrale
lomonosov nous avons repéré des phoques
qui semblait parfaitement à l'aise à
l'idée de nager autour des réacteurs
nucléaires les gens ici espère que le
passage à l'énergie atomique réduira
également la dépendance de pévèle au
charbon qui reste sa principale source
d'énergie
mais si vous voyez
même de nos jours la neige devient
parfois noir à cause des émissions de
l'ancienne centrale thermique à charbon
vous pouvez le voir au loin
en cherchant un refuge accueillant nous
sommes tombés sur une bibliothèque
locale qui est manifestement un lieu
très populaire principalement à cause de
la connexion internet extrêmement lente
en ville à cause de laquelle il est
pénible de regarder netflix ou youtube
et comme il n'ya pas un grand choix de
divertissements les gens lisent des
livres avec deux dames travaillant à la
bibliothèque nous ont offert des
boissons chaudes apparemment le prix
dans les magasins constitue un vaste
sujet de conversation ap bec à bec on a
des toutes petites retraites
c'est impossible de vivre avec ça
et bien d'accord elle en a
une je perds parfois montant au magasin
à réfléchir si je peux me le permettre
ou non même si j'ai envie d'acheter
quelque chose j'achète rarement du
fromage parce qu'un kilo de fromage
c'est 12 15 euros même chose pour le
jambon qui coûte aussi très cher et
qu'avez vous mangez au dîner hier rien
du tout je fais un régime aux
évêques est classé parmi les villes les
plus chères de russie ce qui est logique
car 90% des marchandises sont expédiés
depuis la russie continental des choses
comme les produits alimentaires les
articles ménagers et les vêtements
coûtent beaucoup plus cher qu'à moscou
par exemple regarder les étiquettes
les concombres sont à 11 $ le kilo les
tomates 11 $ le kilo et il ne reste
que deux tomates dans tout le magasin
5 dollars ces quatre à cinq fois plus
cher que disons à moscou où j'habite
mon préféré
cris la ciboule
16 dollars pièce
c'est fou
dans le nord on mange la plupart du
temps des aliments congelés voilà on a
presque que des aliments congelés db
toute la nourriture et congelés pour
avoir quelque chose de frais il faut
attendre qu'on importe quelque chose par
avion c'est à dire qu'on importe des
saucisses par avion à bec oui c'est
dingue il ne faut pas oublier que
beckett une petite communauté soudée de
moins de 5000 personnes
par exemple quelqu'un est à cours
d'argent qui peut emprunter dans un
magasin local
vous avez vu ce cahier miteux que la
commerçante a rapidement cacher c'est
une liste manuscrite de ceux qui doivent
de l'argent en magasin quand on a vécu
20 ans avec cette personne que cette
personne habite juste à côté alors comme
on dit il ne veut pas s'échapper du sous
marin ils achètent quelque chose
aujourd'hui
il le paiera plus tard dans tous les cas
le véritable désastre pour pemex et
quand un navire de ravitaillement
n'arrive pas à temps en raison par
exemple des mauvaises conditions
météorologiques certains magasins locaux
se retrouvent à enfreindre la loi et ne
se débarrasse pas des produits périmés
cette boîte de jus a expiré en juin ya
cinq mois
mais je viens de l'acheter avec une
remise de 50%
c'est une chose courante à québec
quand nous avons montré le jus périmés
au maire-adjoint de québec il s'est
gratté la tête pendant environ une
minute les autorités locales sont
conscientes du problème mais elles ne
peuvent rien faire tant que perec ne
peut pas être approvisionné
régulièrement toute l'année
il ya aussi de bonnes marchandises en
vente mais certains vendeurs sont
négligents autres périodes de navigation
ouvre en juin et ferme en septembre on
ne recevra la plupart des aliments frais
jeu vers la fin de cette période c'est
ça qui influence les prix puisque tout
cela est éliminé ensuite et que personne
ne veut subir des pertes financières
[Musique]
la vie au bout du monde n'est pas un
pique nique si vous voulez survivre dans
un endroit comme celui-ci vous devez
vous serrer les coudes une règle que
tout le monde ici semble respecter une
autre mentalité est différente de celle
des habitants du continent nous sommes
tous comme une grande famille quelle que
soit leur nationalité tout le monde
s'entend bien ici et vous coûte cher et
il fait très froid mais moi j'aime bien
ma ville de québec je vous jure ici j'ai
donné naissance à deux magnifiques
garçons j'ai rencontré l'homme de ma vie
avec ma vraiment beaucoup offert qu'est
ce qui vous fait rester dans cette ville
personne ne le sait tout le monde veut
partir vivre sur le continent mais plus
tard ils reviennent donc si vous êtes
venus ici une fois vous reviendrez aussi
félicitations
avec cette nouvelle centrale
révolutionnaire qui offre de nombreux
emplois et des salaires plus élevés les
choses commencent à s'améliorer pour
québec mais ce n'est pas l'électricité
qui fait changer les choses ce sont les
gens et c'est ça la véritable puissance
de paix bec et de l'arctique russe
[Musique]
oh